We've all lost it at one point or another
during an emotional film.
Sometimes, in just about any movie, all it
takes is a well-timed moment or a single line,
and bam — waterworks.
But the scenes in these movies in particular
crank the sadness up to 11, leaving the audience
practically swimming by the time the credits
roll.
Clear your throat, because we're about to
put a lump in it with the most emotional movies
of all time.
Interstellar
If you've caught Christopher Nolan's space
epic Interstellar, you'll know what's coming
next.
This story of headstrong astronaut Joseph
Cooper, played by Matthew McConaughey, isn't
one you'd anticipate to have you bawling like
a baby, but oh, it absolutely does.
With Earth facing extinction, Cooper and the
crew of the spaceship Endurance head out in
an attempt to find a suitable planet to colonize.
But after getting stranded on one planet for
decades of relative time, Cooper arrives back
on the Endurance to years' worth of messages
from his children, Murphy and Tom.
They were just kids when he left Earth, but
they're now adults.
Compound this with McConaughey's gripping
performance, and this scene leaves you decidedly
not "alright, alright, alright."
Guardians of the Galaxy
For all its high-throttle space action and
hilarious one-liners, Guardians of the Galaxy
still managed to deliver a rich, emotional
story and a couple moments that just broke
the tear bank completely.
One of the most heartfelt parts of the movie
comes right in the opening scene, which sees
young Peter Quill with his mother on her deathbed.
It's bad enough when Peter refuses to take
her hand seconds before she flatlines.
But let's face it — we all lost it when
Peter's grandfather has to pull him screaming
from the room.
"No."
"No!"
Geez, not even five minutes into the movie,
and you're already sobbing into your Milk
Duds.
The Green Mile
Adapted from the 1996 Stephen King novel,
The Green Mile seems like a dark film on the
surface, but what lies below is a web of relationships
that will tug at your heartstrings.
The most touching of all?
John Coffey, played by the late Michael Clarke
Duncan, and Paul Edgecomb, played by Tom Hanks,
who form an unusual alliance at Cold Mountain
Penitentiary, where John is awaiting execution
for a crime he didn't commit.
While The Green Mile has plenty of emotional
moments, one in particular gets the tears
flowing every time.
Even though he's an innocent man, John confides
in Paul that he wants to die, because the
world is too cruel a place for him to live.
Moments before John is killed, Paul steps
forward to shake his hand, a subtle reminder
that their bond was true, and a thank you
for sending him onward.
The Imitation Game
This historical drama brings light to one
of Britain's most brilliant minds: Alan Turing,
the mathematician who became famous for his
efforts to crack the code on the German Enigma
machines during World War II.
Despite his achievements, Turing was subject
to extreme ridicule by the United Kingdom's
legal system following the discovery that
he was in a same-sex relationship with a young
man.
The Imitation Game depicts this arresting
account of discrimination very well, but the
tipping point comes near the end.
Facing the risk of losing his latest machine,
which he named Christopher after a boy he
fell in love with in school, Turing breaks
down in one of the most emotional onscreen
performances in recent years.
Toy Story 3
Pixar has a particular way of pulling at your
emotions, but there was something uniquely
devastating about 2010's Toy Story 3.
Released 11 years after the second installment,
Toy Story 3 had no shortage of hilarious moments
and tongue-in-cheek references, and it also
came with a plotline that drove a nail straight
into its audience's heart: the gang of toys
don't belong to Andy anymore, a circumstance
that leaves their fates hanging by a thread.
During the climax of the film, the whole bunch
end up in an incinerator after an escape plan
goes wrong.
Of course, watching characters you were first
introduced to when you were just a kid in
danger is difficult enough, but the moment
the crew realizes that they're going to die
— and decide to link up hands so they can
face their fate together is next-level cinematic
torture.
You had to have eyes of steel to make it through
that scene without a few tears.
The NeverEnding Story
The 1984 film The NeverEnding Story bills
itself as an epic fantasy, but it could also
be called a "psychological roller-coaster,"
because that's exactly what audiences experience
when they witness Atreyu's horse Artax sink
into the Swamps of Sadness forever.
When the boy-and-horse pair are trekking through
the swamps, Artax gets stuck in the mud and
is too downtrodden to carry on, so he slowly
sinks to his tragic fate — and the camera
doesn't cut away, guaranteeing no one will
step away dry-eyed.
Not even a Luckdragon can make up for this
kind of blow to your emotions.
Good Will Hunting
The late Robin Williams' Oscar-winning performance
as Professor Sean Maguire in the 1997 drama
Good Will Hunting is one of his finest — as
the Academy can clearly tell you — and a
lot of that comes down to one scene.
Matt Damon's Will Hunting is speaking to Sean
about being abused by his foster father, and
the moment spirals into a stunning breakthrough
grounded in a single sentence that sits sincere
amongst a film that's littered with sarcastic
one-liners.
"It's not your fault."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!